okay so now we're going to go to some
more complicated examples and examples
where you'll see the power of of model
speak thanks Trev okay so a uh you know
we've seen how to have design matrices
with just a list of column names you
know a another common uh modeling tool
is an interaction so the way we specify
interactions with model spec is just uh
instead of just having the column name
we put this is a a tupple a twole of the
two column names so this tells model
spec make me an interaction of the
variable lstat and H um so once it's
knows how to create the variable lstat
and the variable age it can make the
interaction between L stat and H okay so
let's just uh fit this model and here we
have a coefficient it's just another
effect in the regression model and in
this case because both lat and age are
quantitative variables it just
multiplies those two together entrywise
yes we'll see in a moment you know there
are Reg ex problems where not all
variables are quantitative in the Boston
Housing data actually all of them are
but um we'll see uh many are categorical
and then uh the interaction would look
different but yeah okay so um another
example you know another modeling tool
that people might use is to rather than
fit just a linear effect for a variable
might put a polinomial effect so um
we've there's a a function poly that
allows us to specify um you know
polinomial effect in some feature here
we'll put a quadratic effect for lstat
and a linear effect for age again the
model is specified the same way it's a
list of terms it's just that this term
here poly has actually two columns
corresponding to it uh let's fit the
model and summarize and we can see that
uh the two columns each one gets a
separate coefficient estimate and
indicated by this is the First Column
corresponding and the second column
because of course the two degree
polinomial has got a quadratic term and
a linear term that's right yeah um and
if we wanted to actually we could uh uh
you could we could consider an
interaction between the polinomial and
age uh but we'll leave that for for
another day
um okay so now this example here we've
gone from just a linear term for lstat
to a quadratic we might be interested in
deciding whether there was really um a
significant Improvement in fit going
from linear to quadratic we can actually
see here that the P value is small but
there's another method that's commonly
used that is the Inova method to compare
two different fitted models so this
Anova LM function from the stats models
what it will do is um Carry Out uh a you
know a test an F test comparing two
nested models uh and we can use that to
decide whether
um one model is significantly better
than the other this F statistic here 177
that's huge that's huge and it's also
should be about 13.3 squared right
that's that t statistic should
correspond to that um though maybe not
exactly I shouldn't I always says it
actually no it should in this case that
should be yes you know okay um let's see
so part of the section that we skipped
looked at residuals uh of our early
regression model and noted a trend in
the residuals plotted as a function of
fitted value in this plot actually we
can see that uh that trend has been
removed um but we didn't see the first
plot so let's not dwell too much on it
the last example we're going to of model
spec we'll we'll use is a um is
qualitative predictors or categorical
variables so uh in the another data set
in the islp package the car seats data
tries to predict the sales of car seets
as a function of different
features um so different features like
uh you
know the uh competitor's price so forget
this maybe a chain like Walmart and
maybe we'll compare it competitor's
price like Target uh maybe this is
income of the uh typical income in the
neighborhood of the of that particular
store Etc one of these variables is
shelf location this is sort of where the
car Siege is placed in the in the sh I
think low medium high are the levels and
so that's you know we could encode low
medium high as 0 1 and two but those are
kind of arbitrary so this is really a
categorical variable I see right um and
uh if we look
at the
column shelf Lo in the uh in the data
frame we'll see whoops that's not right
uh we'll see that it's been recognized
as a category by pendas and so model
spec will then
uh if we use shelf lo as a um as a
predictor it will treat as categorical
so here we have we fit a rather
complicated model um we first found all
the features besides the response sales
and we'll add all those features to the
model and we added a few interactions
just for the fun of it um what we're
going to see is for the variable shelf
Lo sh location which is categorical it
will have uh created more than one
column so here oh I guess rather low
medium high is good medium and poor I
suppose I don't actually know the levels
but so it's it's done what it's done is
it's made dummy variables um for these
three categories and you always need to
leave one of them out because they uh
aliased with the intercept that's right
and and so it's done it all
automatically for you so this is another
instance of things you would normally
have to do yourself to set up the model
Matrix this m has Ms model spec has just
done it all for you make made it much
easier yes and there of course there are
various ways you can you can add these
two columns so experts you can if
experts in specifying these can can do
it their own way if you like but we're
definitely not going to draw on that
okay so that brings us to the the end of
the lab on on regression and um next Lab
is uh we'll see you next week for
classification